retomemos la situación que hemos estado
viendo ya en varios vídeos especialmente
en el último video en donde buscábamos
este marco de referencia neutral verdad
y de hecho podríamos retomar todo el
problema teníamos digamos el observador
que se encuentra en esta nave espacial a
verdad bert y teníamos que se encuentra
en un marco de referencia inercial muy
bien y además supusimos que al tiempo de
igual a cero entonces teníamos un
personaje ve que se movía justamente
0.8 veces la velocidad de la luz muy
bien y justo pasaba el tiempo cero por
encima de nosotros verdad y allá y
nosotros ya sabemos ver los diagramas
encimados verdad donde podemos ver estos
ejes oblicuos verdad y si queremos
por ejemplo fijarnos en el cambio en el
tiempo por ejemplo vamos a comparar
estos eventos vamos a comparar estos
eventos digamos que vamos a comparar
este primer evento en el origen y un
evento que se encuentre digamos al
variar 7 muy bien entonces vamos a poner
aquí ahora sí vamos a ver aquí un cambio
muy bien entonces ahí tenemos el camión
se te gustó este evento que tenemos en
el origen es cuando la nave pasa por
arriba de nosotros verdad y podemos ver
que nuestro marco de referencia ocurre
digamos en exactamente el mismo lugar
espacial verdad en realidad lo único que
está cambiando es el tiempo pero si nos
preguntamos cuánto tiempo se para estos
eventos verdad desde el punto de vista
ahora debe lo que tenemos que hacer es
trazar esta línea paralela al eje en
este caso x prima verdad trazamos una
línea paralela al eje x prima y entonces
donde intersecta ahí podemos medir
verdad ahí podemos o más bien podríamos
ver cuál sería el cambio en sete prima
muy bien ahí podríamos ver el cambio en
7 prima y en principio en principio
parece más largo verdad pero recordemos
que hasta este momento
mostrado cuáles son las escalas de todo
esto y de hecho las escalas cambian
dependiendo de las velocidades relativas
muy bien pero podríamos ver algebraica
mente que justamente el cambio en sete
prima es más grande que el cambio en
sete muy bien y para hacer para ver esto
usaremos las transformaciones de lorentz
entonces vamos a calcular el cambio en 7
prima esto será igual a gamma nuestro
factor de lawrence que multiplica al
cambio en 7 menos beta veces el cambio
x muy bien entonces esta estas
transformaciones ya las hemos visto en
otros vídeos pero aquí si observamos
cuál es el cambio en x el cambio en x en
este caso es 0 así que este término no
no no aparece verdad en realidad todo
esto es estacionario en nuestro marco de
referencia así que podríamos concluir
que el cambio en 7 prima será igual a
gamma que multiplica al cambio en 7
entonces lo único que necesitamos ver es
más o menos quienes gamma en este caso
gamma será igual a 1 sobre la raíz
cuadrada de 1 menos la velocidad
relativa que en este caso es 0.8 veces c
dividido sobre si todo esto elevado al
cuadrado verdad pero en este caso las s
se cancelan y lo que obtenemos es
dividido entre la raíz vamos a hacerlo
digamos mentalmente tendremos la raíz
cuadrada de uno menos el cuadrado de 0.8
pero el cuadrado de 0.8 es 0.64 verdad y
si a uno le restamos 0.64 tendremos 0.36
y si sacamos la raíz cuadrada cuadrada
de 0.36 tendremos 0.6 verdad y esto 0.6
son 6 decimos verdad 1 entre seis
décimos serían 10 sextos podemos sacar
mitad verdad y tendremos 5 tercios 5
tercios son 11 un entero y dos tercios
muy bien entonces puedes ver justamente
que el cambio en 7 prima será uno y dos
tercios
eso multiplicando al cambio
de verdad y uno podría decir que esta
distancia esta distancia que tenemos
aquí es un entero dos tercios del cambio
en siete de verdad y aunque parece eso
por el dibujo en realidad no podemos
digamos como como tomar una regla
calcular la longitud de ambos verdad por
esto que las está las escalas en
principio son distintas pero ahora
pensemos qué es lo que ocurre desde el
otro marco de referencia así que tomemos
otro evento vamos a tomar otro evento
digamos con este color de aquí sale
entonces tomemos este otro evento de
aquí que ahora tenga un cambio
7 prima bien tenemos en ese evento de
ahí que tiene un cambio en 7 prima con
respecto al origen muy bien y entonces
otra vez qué pasa si queremos observar
cuál es el cambio en ct bueno pues
tendremos que trazar una recta paralela
al eje x y ver dónde intercepta al eje 7
en este caso sería aquí verdad y el
cambio en 7 tendría que ser esto el
cambio en
y en principio otra vez parece más largo
pero en realidad lo podemos ver
claramente si lo hacemos con álgebra
verdad entonces el cambio en sete será
igual a gamma veces el cambio en sete
prima menos beta veces el cambio en x
prima verdad en este caso otra vez el
cambio en x prima es 0 verdad es un
evento que es estacionario desde el
punto de vista de b y entonces esto será
igual a gamma que en este caso será
igual a un anterior un entero dos
tercios verdad será exactamente igual en
este caso en este caso será gamma que
multiplica al cambio en siete prima así
que esta en realidad parece un poco
extraño verdad un paso del tiempo en mi
marco de referencia digamos con con un
movimiento estacionario parece que ese
evento toma más tiempo para para ocurrir
digamos en el marco de referencia que se
está
análogamente si tenemos dos eventos
estacionarios verdad en el marco de
referencia debe resulta ser que el
cambio en sete es mayor y por ello para
ayudarnos a visualizar lo mucho mejor y
de hecho para poner acepte y acepte
prima digamos a la misma escala
podemos usar el marco de referencia
neutral que tenemos justamente aquí
entonces vamos a movernos un poquito
aquí tenemos un marco de referencia
neutral entonces sólo recordemos de cómo
es que construimos este marco de
referencia neutral aquí teníamos que ver
se mueve a una velocidad de 0.8 veces la
velocidad de la luz en la dirección
positiva del eje horizontal verdad
cuando a está en un estado estacionario
ahora bien cuando ves se encuentra en un
estado estacionario entonces se mueve a
menos 0.8 veces la velocidad de la luz
pero en dirección negativa del eje
horizontal verdad eso era lo que
teníamos
aquí pero pudimos hacer un marco de
referencia donde tanto a como ve que se
alejan ambos a una velocidad de 0.5
veces la velocidad de la luz verdad y se
alejan de un origen verdad donde nos
encontrábamos con este personaje se y lo
que es genial de todo esto es que si
hacemos el diagrama de espacio-tiempo de
minkowski en es en ese marco de
referencia neutral
entonces los ejes tanto sete como el
como el eje se te prima tienen la misma
inclinación a la izquierda verdad ya la
derecha respectivamente y dado que
tienen la misma inclinación entonces la
escala relativa a este marco será la
misma entonces aquí podríamos poner una
marca que corresponde a la misma escala
de este lado podríamos poner otra marca
aquí que corresponde también a la misma
marca oa la misma escala del otro lado
verdad de hecho podemos ver que tanto
los ejes
y prima como xvii prima por ejemplo aquí
están pintados verdad tanto los ejes de
mi prima como x mi prima también los
dibujé en ambos
en los otros marcos de referencia o
quizás debería decir en los otros
diagramas y de hecho se hallan entre los
ejes de ambos verdad de ambos marcos de
referencia pero si ahora regresamos al
marco de referencia neutral muy bien y
si nos fijamos en estos dos eventos
cuando tenemos el cambio en siete que ya
entonces vamos a poner aquí el cambio en
siete es que sea justamente esto aquí
está el cambio en
quizás debería hacerlo un poquito más
claro aquí tendremos el cambio en sete
muy bien entonces vemos que si ahora nos
fijamos en la coordenada ct prima verdad
si nos fijamos en la coordenada 7 prima
tendremos que estirarlo por un factor de
un entero más dos tercios
es más o menos estará hasta acá y esto
de aquí será el cambio en 7 prima muy
bien ahí tenemos el cambio en 7 prima en
justamente esta posición lo único que
tendríamos que hacer es pintar una línea
paralela al eje x prima y ahí justamente
donde intersecta tendremos nuestra
posición de este evento verdad en este
marco de referencia por otro lado si
ahora nos fijamos en este otro evento
verdad del que habíamos puesto con azul
si ahora tenemos justamente digamos esto
de aquí va a ser delta se te verdad
prima esto será delta se te prima
entonces sí sí ahora lo pensamos en el
marco de referencia de a siguiendo el
eje x verdad siguiendo el eje x vamos a
tener que intersecta más o menos
hay verdad ahí tenemos que intersecta al
eje
aléjese de verdad siguiendo al eje x y
este sería nuestro cambio en sete verdad
pero visto ahora desde el marco de
referencia de a y lo que es realmente
interesante de todo esto es que desde el
marco de referencia de a el evento
amarillo ocurre antes de lo que ocurre
en el marco de referencia ve en cambio
en el marco de referencia debe el evento
azul ocurre antes que el evento amarillo
verdad así que puedes ver que están
ocurriendo cosas realmente fascinantes
pero lo que realmente me gusta de este
diagrama es que los marcos de referencia
de aire tienen la misma escala ya que
tienen la misma inclinación con respecto
a este eje verdad solo que está uno
hacia la izquierda y el otro
la derecha y a este tipo de diagrama se
le conoce como diagrama de loeb el que
este tipo de diagrama es un diagrama de
quizás no lo estoy pronunciando bien
pero así se escribe déjenme escribirlo
correctamente diagrama d
diagrama de fuego muy bien y en realidad
es una ligera variación del diagrama de
minkowski pero nos permite apreciar la
simetría entre estos dos marcos de
referencia